you first explain what our mix logic is
what the purpose of this program is and
hopefully we can also get to know about
you and your background i see some of
you have already shared where you're
from
maybe some of you have questions so that
will be great and you can keep those
questions coming
so onyx logic and i would like to first
take you to uh the portal
just to make sure that everybody's going
to be have access to a lot of the things
that we will cover
so the first thing that i would like to
ask you to do is really
join us uh here on the portal
so if you do have your microphone on uh
please keep it on mute for now uh you
don't need to turn on your video either
but
first of all this is the portal
where a lot of the materials that we
will be covering in today's session and
in the sessions that will come in the
following several weeks will be posted
i'll guide you through but to have
access you should be logged in and you
should be able to see
what i see here and and that includes
your email address right here on top
so let's just take a moment
right now if you could go to this link
check that you are signed in the
registration is free
and all you need to do is create a
password and a login and once you're in
please put number one or yes in the chat
box so that i know that you are in here
so here as you can see i am logged in
and i can see my name my email address
right here on the top and if i click on
it i will be redirected to my profile
all right excellent thank you mohamed
maureen marvelous okay excellent so i'll
just give it one
more minute for everybody to be able to
log in and find your way around and what
i wanted to ask you to do
and thank you davi so if you're in you
should be able to click on your email
address and arrive right here to your
profile and i will explain a little bit
why this profile is the center place of
this whole portal and why it's important
to start this program by visiting this
profile
so as you can imagine
we will cover a lot of different topics
and not everything can be covered in our
live sessions
a lot of what you will have access to
will be also available in an
asynchronous way which means that you
can access it whenever you have time
whenever you want to practice things
whenever you want to remember what we
did
once you have signed up
from this account you will be able to
access
courses and
the key thing is this tab called
programs
so the program that we are discussing
today is data science for biomedical
data analysis
this is the link to the main program
page thank you just me
and on this page you should find all of
the necessary information
that you will need to succeed in this
program and i will discuss briefly what
does it mean to succeed in this program
and how do you know that you have
succeeded
so here if you scroll down
you should be able to see that for each
session like today's session you have
some associated online resources so
these resources are accessible at any
time and after you after we have a
session like two days you will see here
a recording of that session so you
should be able to go through all of
these sessions for the duration of the
program and at the end once you complete
all of these sessions you will also
receive a certificate
and so that's the first place that you
need to
kind of navigate and take a look at if
you have any questions about the
curriculum which we will go over today
as well
so once you are signed in this is a page
where you see before you have to join
the program and after you have joined
the program you will see the additional
information like the recordings the
certificate etc and all of that
information is going to be accessible
under your profile under the programs
tab
so here you will see if this is the only
program that you're taking just that
program if you have taken or are
planning to take other programs any
program that you have signed up for you
will see it right here and you will be
able to track your progress in the
program
by seeing the completed sessions
right here
under that program itself
okay so the second thing that i wanted
to point out is that the program
consists of a number of courses and
today we will give you a brief view of
what these courses include
but the first course that i would like
to
kind of bring your attention to
is a course called introduction to
bioinformatics
and bytes and molecules
and i will explain briefly why these are
the two courses where we like to begin
and i will do that by just sharing my
screen and showing you the first lesson
in the first
in this course
and the first lesson is more of an
opportunity to learn about you so that
we can adapt the materials that we cover
in this program to your level and your
interests so if you go to this course
and thank you or jesse if you could
please
put the link to this course as well
thank you
so in this course it's a free course if
you join the program if you didn't join
the program we encourage you to take
this course it will provide you with a
high level overview of what we
kind of
seek to address in the topic of
bioinformatics but here you will find a
brief survey
and if you haven't taken the survey i
highly encourage you to take this survey
as we do today's session so that we can
understand your background so your
current level of education your
occupation which basically means are you
involved in research are you in industry
are you a student so we would like to
know that as well
okay if you don't see the survey you
need to go to
this course introduction to
bioinformatics and the first lesson
introduction to big data bioinformatics
and you should be able to see this
survey
okay
so now we also want to understand if
you're from a particular university or
organization that would be very helpful
for us we have multiple organizations
that we are working with and we would
like to know your previous
bioinformatics experience so if you
already have a phd in bioinformatics or
you don't know anything in
bioinformatics will greatly help us
provide you with the right assistance
that you need we think that this program
could be useful for anyone for people
that have an advanced experience in
bioinformatics or have no experience in
bioinformatics and i will explain in a
little bit how we are going to address
the different levels of experience that
people have
okay the link for the survey is already
posted or just we just shared the link
right there on top learn onlinelogic.com
courses and the course is called
introduction to bioinformatics
okay
now we also will cover a number of
different data sets and data types and
that is why we also ask about your
interests right here below
we provided here just a few different
options so maybe something that you're
interested in is not listed out and
that's why you have an additional
question here at the end about anything
else that you would like us to know if
you have a specific interest a project
that you're working on
or maybe a specific data type or a
biological condition or a medical
condition you will you can put that in
there and that would be very helpful for
us as well so the objective of today's
session is number one to get to know
each other so we would love to get to
know you and we will tell you a little
bit about us and our team you will get
to see what we do in action so we can do
that together and we will also review
some of the coursework and the material
that we will cover throughout the
program so that you understand how the
different topics will be addressed
during the session
does anyone have any questions so far if
you do please put your questions in the
chat and i will take a pause every few
minutes so that we can address those
questions in detail and answer them
hopefully in today's session or tell you
about when we will cover
that topic in the future
okay so as i mentioned this is where we
begin we really want to make sure that
you have a profile
and when you have that profile all of
the activity and information that is
collected about you will be available
under that profile not only for you
but also for our mentors
so when our mentors are interacting with
you when you have any questions they
will refer back to your profile and they
will try to identify your level of
experience and help find the right kind
of an opportunity for you to learn
anything that you might be missing
from
this experience
so this
leads into the process of certification
so the the goal of this program could
mean several different things so
probably many of you are coming from
different backgrounds and we're just
getting to know you we would like this
program to be as effective as possible
for each one of you and provide you with
the value that you need but to do that
we really need to identify what might be
the potential outcomes for this program
so this is a program that will allow you
to understand a variety of methods
for
data science and i will briefly describe
what these methods are so the outcome
that we're looking at first is a
comprehensive overview of data science
methods so what would that include in
the context of biomedical data
number one you will be able to
understand a variety of omics data types
you will be able to perform exploratory
data analysis so that you know how to
explore and understand what does this
data represent whether it's microbiome
data transcriptome data medical and
clinical indicators for a variety of
diseases or this is data that you can
generate using different high throughput
techniques like next generation
sequencing so a variety of data types an
overview of what they are and how to
deal with them will be the first portion
of this program
the second portion of this program is
exploring that kind of data structuring
that data preparing it for analysis and
really understanding the characteristics
of that data
then we will talk about big data there
are many challenges with big data that
are not standard for the types of tables
that you might be used to working with
and so to understand the full process
from raw to
analyzed an interpretable signal is
going to be a priority for this program
and a big part of that is understanding
a variety of different methods methods
that include
statistical analysis
and machine learning as well as deep
learning and we hope to cover the
conceptual as well as practical aspects
of those methods
and then finally we would like you to be
able to understand the link between the
selection of methods that you take
during the project
and the biological
background and interpretation so the
link between biology and the methods
that you select is very important in
this program perhaps more important than
the actual technical skills that you
might gain as a result of practicing a
lot of the analyses in different
examples that we will provide you with
now you do have an option
for the duration of the program to focus
on an independent project right and i'm
going to address briefly the question
here that indrani biswas is asking in
the chat so she's asking
uh can you kind uh sorry she's asking
will we be able to publish what we get
our project right or for example using
machine learning i want to make it work
for designing effective treatment
strategies for cancer so excellent
question right and that speaks about the
application of data science methods to
particular types of diseases like cancer
or particular types of data perhaps
clinical data if we're talking about
treatment and indicators of the
biological condition for that data which
might be sequencing data genomics
transcriptomics etc right so we'll talk
about that and that will be a lot of uh
what you will be exposed to but i
briefly want to point you back
to the portal and show you how do the
projects fit into this process
so
as i mentioned
earlier under your profile
is where you will have access to a
variety of coursework which includes
project examples
as well as an independent project that
you would be able to submit at the end
of this process
the
later part of today's presentation will
deal specifically with that question how
do you take what you have learned and
apply it to an independent project and
perhaps advance towards publication
right so a publication might take quite
a
long time but you will definitely be
able to get started on that process and
then it's just up to you on how fast you
will be able to finish but i will show
you some examples of previous
participants and the projects that they
were able to complete during a program
like this
so let me go back briefly to this slide
and kind of start explaining how do all
of these things fit into this program so
again we're talking about different
types of data we're talking about
exploring and understanding this data
analyzing this data using statistical
analysis and machine learning and
learning about the link between biology
and data science how do these things
link together and so the way we're going
to do this is we're going to provide you
with curated data sets throughout this
program we will explain how these data
sets were generated in expert labs
because we will be taking data sets from
the public domain so they come with a
publication you will be able to read
those publications and understand them
and then we will reproduce aspects of
those publications in the exercises that
we perform to evaluate how methods
compare to address a specific challenge
or a question that those people had so
that you get a better understanding of
the topic as well as a better
understanding of the methods and how
they are applied